it is the last stud one last mission one
last myth to bust and only two men have
the skills to do the job for 14 years
Adam Savage and Jamie Hyneman
have been warriors for truth in the land
of well a lot of stupid stuff
armed with engineering skills born of
years in the visual effects business and
a ton of science know-how not to mention
some wonderful toys the guys made
science fun and the world smarter now
they're saying goodbye in classic
Mythbusters style
this is the last stunt of the last
episode of the last season
today we are driving a truck ram through
the whole history of the mythbusters
series i've been going through this
whole sea of emotions over the past few
months I mean we've been doing this for
40 weeks a year for thirteen and a half
years in 2014 Jamie and the crew built a
huge steel beak onto a big rig to plow
through traffic
now Adams going to drive it through a
mile of the show's best props over the
years there's the diet coke and mentos
cascade the duct-tape life rafts and
even the shadow rocket-powered Chevy
Impala alright here we go this is the
destructive drive down memory lane B
obviously it's gonna be fun but the show
has always had a deeper message that
science is rad we learned along the
process that just being methodical and
careful about your work well that's
science science and engineering are not
just things for guys in lab coats it's
for anybody that wants to learn more
about their world
Mythbusters prefigured maker culture and
it proved that hackers and geeks didn't
always have to be the sidekick they
could also be heroes three two one
we're not going to show you the whole
stunt that'd be a spoiler and you're
gonna watch it anyway
the primary message of this show has
always been about being curious that's
what I keep getting back from the fans
and it is a great lesson that when you
follow your enthusiasm a lot of other
things fall into place and I'm really
grateful for both having it seems
propagated that message but also how
much I've learned it us to guys thanks
for 14 years of deeply cool nerdery